cette journée là l'accueil a été
triomphal après trois mises en
candidatures infructueuses
quelle gare et donné le coup d'envoi à
ces jeux olympiques le 13 février 1990
la métropole albertaine était bien
différente à l'époque sa population
était la moitié de celle d'aujourd'hui
ces installations sportives étaient
presque inexistante
mais cette absence d'infrastructures
n'avait pas pour autant freiner les
ardeurs du comité olympique local
présidé par frank king pas
d'installation pas de problème c'était
devenu l'argument de vente d'utile pour
obtenir ce rendez vous international de
la saône et l'anneau olympique
le parc olympique winsport le syndrome
la place olympique des infrastructures
qui sont toutes encore aujourd'hui au
service des calgariens de la communauté
sportive a lui aussi participé à la mise
en oeuvre de ce grand événement
l'héritage de ces jeux se résume d'après
lui en quelques mots installations et
esprit olympique les jeux ont changé le
visage de calgary et l'ont transformée
en véritable plaque tournante des sports
d'hiver au canada
à preuve bon nombre d'organismes
nationaux sont aujourd'hui basés ici
le président du comité international
olympique avait qualifié ces jeux
d'hiver comme étant les plus réussies de
l'histoire il y a trente ans frank qui
avait visé juste
esprit des jeux vivra pour toujours à
calgary avait-il déclaré à la cérémonie
de clôture
[Musique]
le succès de ces jeux et les
infrastructures toujours en place font
de calgary une candidate sérieuse pour
les jeux olympiques d'hiver de 2026 le
conseil municipal cependant ne prendra
aucune décision formelle avant d'avoir
l'assurance qu'elle me tenais ottawa
appuyé financièrement une mise en
candidature ici geneviève normes à radio
canada calgary
[Musique]